jumping into taboo so I watched the
first season we talked a long time ago
and when I saw Tom Hardy last I said oh
so where's the second season get off
your ass and sorry where is the second
season
it's almost completed in terms of the
script we had to cut the delays because
of other commitments but we are hoping
to start shooting end of this year of
the start next ok so it's definitely
coming
yes it's and how does is there a time
jump from the first season is it because
I believe if I'm not mistaken it was
designed as a three season show it still
will be I mean I you know if I if we all
stick with it and we all want to keep
doing it would be through that's that's
my plan because I've got a geographical
sort of route for the thing to take and
it's basically a journey West and so
yeah I mean I I have a destination in
mind which is always nice to have if
you're you know if you're setting up on
this a big journey which is what writing
three eight hours is it's good to know
where you're heading and so it's another
eight hours for season two yeah yeah I
am I'm saying awesome you have a great
relationship with Tom you've worked
together a number of times what is it
does he have compromising pictures of
you or do you have compromising pictures
of him it's really strange because I
think it works because we don't
socialize you know we do occasionally
but not very often and I think that the
relationship is totally about the work
and the great thing about Tom is that's
his passion is the work there of the
acting you know he he's not a fan of
celebrity but he just loves to act and
he loves the process and the craft and
for me to have him occasionally
available to do roles that you've
written is is wonderful because you know
you know you can trust someone to to
really deliver what you do and I mean
Locke and and taboo were sort of came
about because of each other where I was
invited to meet Tom to
talk about writing this thing to boo and
I was developing LOC and Tom was parking
his car and I spoke to his manager and
said that do you mind if I mentioned
this project he said no so we did a deal
where he would do LOC if I did to me
that's so funny
you